SPEAKER: Good
afternoon, everyone.
How are we doing?
[AUDIENCE SOUNDS]
SPEAKER: There we go.
Yes.
We're running a little
bit late, so I'll
go ahead and jump
right to it, but it's
my pleasure and privilege
to invite Ryan Holiday.
He's a writer and strategist.
He's worked with the likes
of Tim Ferris, Google,
Complex Media, and several
other bestselling authors.
And now he's here to talk
to us about his new book,
"Ego is the Enemy."
Previously, he has
written three other books.
The last one, "The
Obstacle is the Way,"
has become a big
success with the likes
of NFL players, rappers,
and competitive athletes.
So we're very lucky
to have him here
and we're excited to hear
about his [INAUDIBLE] book.
So please give him
a warm welcome.
Thank you.
RYAN HOLIDAY: Thanks, buddy.
Awesome.
Is this the clicker?
SPEAKER: Yes.
RYAN HOLIDAY: OK, perfect.
How's everyone doing?
This is my first
talk for the book,
so I hope you can enjoy
being my test audience.
Actually, no, I made this
one up just for you guys.
I hope I'm not biting the hand
that feeds me a little bit,
but there are some
Google mentions.
So we'll get into it.
I set out to write a
book a few years ago,
actually, that the topic was
going to be about humility.
That ended up being much
harder than I thought.
And as I was meditating
on this idea-- oh,
there's a monitor up there.
Very cool.
As I was meditating
on this idea,
it occurred to me-- actually,
I remember exactly where I was.
I was standing in the
American Apparel parking
lot, because unlike
Google, we didn't
have all these
awesome pods where you
could take private phone calls.
So I was on the phone and I
was thinking about this book
and I was talking
it through, and it
occurred to me that we're all
in one of three phases in life.
You can actually
see the evolution
of the drawings of the idea.
You can see that weird
mouth-looking drawing.
The idea is at first, we're
aspiring to something.
Then, from that aspiration,
either comes success
or we fail at that thing.
And we're constantly repeating
through these things.
I do all my books on these
four by six note cards.
So these are the first four
note cards of the book.
The idea is you're aspiring
to get some taste of success,
then you succeed,
maybe you plateau, then
you begin to get
complacent, and you fail
and then you're
back to aspiration.
Or you succeed and you want
to aspire to something else.
This is the idea.
And what occurred
to me-- instead
of talking about humility,
I would talk about ego.
Because ego is the
opposite of what you need
at any of those three phases.
As Cyril Connolly says,
"Ego sucks us down
like the law of gravity."
Again, I'm not talking about
ego in the Freudian sense--
which, even after a fair
amount of reading about,
I still don't quite understand.
I'm talking about ego
in the colloquial sense.
The group of traits
that we associate
with ego-- selfishness,
delusion, arrogance, greed,
endless competitiveness.
What we mean when
we say, oh, that's
all ego-- that's what
I'm referring to.
Not the Ego, per a
psychologist's definition.
And so again, ego-- depending
on whether we're aspiring,
so we're just
starting out, we're
trying to do something--
ego is the worst element
you can introduce into that.
Those traits are the worst
things that you can do.
And then, when we succeed, if
that aspiration is made real,
ego manifests
itself in a new way.
Now the arrogance
is more pronounced,
let's say, or we start to have
control over other people.
So that ego manifests itself
in our leadership styles,
in our management systems.
We can start to tell ourselves
this story about who we are
and how we got to where
we are, which we'll
talk a little bit more about.
And then, often, because
ego is the root of--
or is undermining our
success, we get into failure.
Or something turns out to be
harder than what we expected,
we have some crisis or scandal.
And now again, ego
is a negative element
to introduce into your
life because instead
of learning a lesson,
it's taking from this
that it's other people's fault
or that you'll never recover.
So ego is manifesting itself
in profoundly different ways
wherever we happen
to be in life,
but in every single phase,
it's a negative trait.
And so my premise is
that ego is the enemy.
And I love this quote
from Richard Feynman,
where he's saying, "The first
principle is that you must not
fool yourself-- and you are
the easiest person to fool."
That's ego.
Ego is fooling us
precisely when we
need to be fully in
command of all our senses,
we need to be aware of
the objective reality
of our situations, we need to
understand what we're good at,
what we're bad at.
And so ego is fooling us.
And I make a
distinction in the book
between confidence and ego.
I say confidence is
earned and ego is stolen.
Ego is fooling yourself.
So that's the
premise of the book.
Obviously, I thought
it'd a little absurd if I
came to Google and
I talked to one
of the world's most
valuable companies--
it might be the world's
most valuable company.
I know you guys are
always like this.
But it would be foolish for me
to come here and talk to you
about aspiring to do something.
As a company level,
obviously, you've
achieved an incredible amount.
And even just to
work here, that's
an incredible accomplishment.
So I won't talk
about that and things
are going pretty well
for Google these days,
so I'm not going to
lecture you on how
to recover from failure
because, clearly, that's
not a problem either.
I wanted to talk about success--
the way in which success
can breed ego and undermine the
things that we're trying to do.
And so there's a
chapter in the book,
and the story I
wanted to tell today
is, ironically, about not
telling yourself a story.
And the way that ego
can work and change
the stories that we tell
ourselves and, ultimately, lead
us astray.
To me-- Nassim Teleb-- he calls
this the narrative fallacy--
the way that we cobble
together the events of our past
into a personal narrative.
Not just personally, but
sometimes about history.
We connect disconnected
events and we
create a sense of
certainty and cohesion
that's not really there.
As David Maraniss said, "Myth
becomes myth not in the living
but in the retelling."
And so when we reflect
back on our success,
or when we read about our
success in the media-- success
about projects we've
worked on or things
we've been a part
of-- the ego is there
puffing these things up
and making them different
than they actually were.
And so the story
I tell in the book
is the story of Bill
Walsh, who in 1979, took
over the San Francisco 49ers.
At that point,
they were not just
one of the worst
teams in football.
They may have been
one of the worst teams
in all of professional sports.
Took over as the general
manager and the coach--
he'd previously been
the coach at Stanford--
and he immediately set
about trying to change.
They were fully ensconced
in a culture of losing.
It was a bad franchise.
In fact, the year before he took
over, the team was two and 14.
And then he took over.
And he did a lot of work, he
drafted some good players.
But that season-- the
first season as a coach--
they were two and 14 again.
And not only two and 14,
they currently-- or they
still-- hold the record for the
only team to lead in 12 games
and still lose them.
So it was a miserable,
horrible season.
And then the next season
was almost as bad.
They went six and 10 in 1980.
But they were so bad
that year that he almost
quit about halfway
through the season.
And so it was a pretty bad ride.
And the next season,
they won the Super Bowl.
They beat the
Cincinnati Bengals.
This is the season that
features the catch, maybe
one of the most famous
plays in all of football.
But they win.
And here he is, hoisted on
the shoulders of his players.
And he is quickly
hailed as the genius.
He turned a team around
in probably the shortest
amount of time in NFL history.
Again, he took it from
the worst franchise
to the best franchise
in three seasons.
This is unheard of.
And yet, Bill Walsh--
even at that time--
there's a famous
article where they're
talking about his
response to the victory.
What he was-- the announcer
says, oh, he must be numb.
Because he was sitting there,
not looking, on the sidelines.
In fact, Bill Walsh
told the announcer later
that he was just thinking
about the next season.
But he's quickly decried as
the greatest name in football.
And he put all that aside.
He ignored that label.
And he not only
ignored the narrative
of taking it from the worst
to the best at the time,
but even when he writes
his memoirs years later,
he's still resisting that.
And the reason is, he knew that
what was actually responsible
for the 49ers winning
was what he called
the standard of performance.
And this was the standard
that he put on his players
at the time.
And they were pretty stringent.
There was no sitting
on the playing fields,
coaches had to wear
a suit and ties,
sportsmanship was stressed
almost to an absurd degree,
work ethic was prized
above all things.
No fighting, no swearing.
All these things were banned.
Linemen were drilled on
these 30 different drills,
which is a lot for linemen.
Passing routes for
receivers were actually
measured down to the inch.
And the practices were
scheduled down to the minute.
And so what Walsh
had always said
is that if we adhere to these
standards of performance--
if we take care of them-- the
score will take care of itself.
And so what he was
focused on, then,
was not turning
around this franchise.
He said that the first question
he was asked by reporters
was always, what's your
timetable for turning
around the 49ers?
And what he would say,
over and over again,
is I don't have a timetable.
And he really meant it.
One of the assistant
coaches at the time
actually complained
to the boss that Walsh
didn't have a
timetable and that it
wasn't going to be fast enough.
And Walsh fired him.
So Walsh's point was,
actually, I don't
know when we're going to win.
And I don't know how
long it's going to take.
All I know is that if we adhere
to these standards, eventually,
we will win.
He said that the
job of a coach is
to help a team make a
base camp near the summit.
And so if you sketch that
metaphor out a little bit, what
he's saying is you make
base camp near the summit,
and then only
weather permitting,
do you make that run.
And so it just happened,
as he understood it,
that the run to the
summit-- to the Super Bowl--
was within three seasons instead
of seven seasons, or even
one season.
And so what he was
resisting, then,
because he was actually
there at the time--
he knew that it wasn't
so simple as worst team
in football to best
team in football.
And he knew that the
story, telling himself
that he was a genius, or that
the team might tell itself
a story that they were the
best-- that they were somehow
special-- that this was a
very dangerous thing to do.
And in fact, the
next two seasons,
the Super Bowl-- as
often happens to teams,
when they win,
they start to be--
the bonds that bring the
team together start to fray,
egos start to come in.
The 49ers lost 12 of
the next 22 games.
But Walsh stuck
with what he thought
was important, which was these
standards of performance.
And so what happens, though,
when you're successful,
is that other people try
to remove that context--
that sort of nitty gritty.
The idea that he
almost quit halfway
through because he didn't
think it was working
or that it was the little
things that mattered and not
his bold, audacious plans.
The narrative that's
built around you
and that you build
around yourself
starts to overpower the
reality of your situation.
Tobias Wolff-- who's actually
a professor at Stanford
and a brilliant
short story writer--
he's saying that, all of
this gets cobbled together
later, and sincerely so,
and after the stories get
repeated enough times, they
put on the badge of memory
and-- this is the
important part--
they block the routes
of exploration.
So you stop being able to see
your own life objectively.
You've repeated this
story enough times
that it starts to become true.
And so that's what
Walsh was resisting,
not only at the time,
but then decades later.
And the reason is--
again-- is that stories,
they don't change the past.
You can tell yourself whatever
you want about the past.
The problem is that what you
tell yourself about the past,
particularly if it's
a flattering way,
it can change your future.
It changes how you
respond to things.
So it's about making sure that
we learn the right lessons
from our stories.
That we're telling
ourselves the right stories.
And a few years ago
I worked on a book
with Peter Diamandis
and Steven Kotler.
I did the marketing for it.
And as I was watching
some of the videos
that they had produced,
there was a video
that Peter had
hosted at Singularity
University and your CEO and
brilliant co-founder-- he
spoke at.
And he said this line
on stage and I thought
it was really interesting.
He said, "I now have a
very simple metric I use."
And this is for companies that
he invests in or acquires.
He's saying, "Are you
working on something
that can change the world?
Yes or no?"
And this is a very
inspiring thing.
And I remember when I saw it,
I was like that's awesome.
And then I thought a
little bit more about it
and I wondered if there isn't a
little bit of that storytelling
going on the way that we can
look backwards at ourselves
and create clarity or vision
that wasn't necessarily there.
And it struck me that I'm not
sure some of Google's biggest
successes would
meet that criteria.
Not at the time.
Here's the Stanford PhD
paper that Larry and Sergey
wrote together.
They weren't trying necessarily
to create a company that
would change the world.
It wasn't this bold,
brilliant vision
to create billions and billions
of dollars worth of wealth
and employ thousands
of thousands of people,
and create all these different,
interesting products.
It was exploring,
theoretically, an idea of how
search might be organized.
Or if you look at YouTube.
People forget
because the narrative
that the media tells
glosses over this.
In fact, even the
YouTube founders
talk about it differently.
But YouTube started
as a dating site.
And this is the first video
ever uploaded on YouTube.
And you can see this
cool-- he's at the zoo,
I guess, talking about how
he likes to go to the zoo
and maybe you would want to
come to the zoo with him.
And so here's a quote from him.
He's saying, "We
didn't even know how
to describe our new product.
To generate interest,
we just said that it
was a new kind of dating site.
We even had a slogan for
it-- tune in, hook up."
So obviously, what YouTube
is now and what it's done
is almost unbelievable.
But it can be easy to
forget what it actually
was when it started.
And I think Gmail the same way.
I've heard some
conflicting reports
that the idea was
always to do Gmail
or really it was a
Google 20% project.
In any case, not
everyone thought
it was a good idea at the time.
Here's Paul, who created Gmail.
He's saying, "A lot
of people thought
it was a very bad idea,
both from a product
and a strategic standpoint."
They thought maybe it
would piss off competitors
or that it wouldn't work.
That it was outside search.
And then Brian Rakowski, who
was the first project manager
on Gmail-- he's saying "It
didn't look anything like what
Gmail does now or
even what it looked"--
that it was just
radically different.
And here's a screenshot.
My favorite part
of this screenshot.
Can I do a laser point?
If you see-- whoever
took this screenshot
was also on something awful.
But I think it's pretty awesome.
This is Gmail when it launched.
It's radically different
than what it was.
And actually, Jeff Bezos has
talked about this a little bit,
too.
He has to remind himself
over and over again--
because it's what
reporters want to hear--
that there was no aha moment
in the creation of Amazon.
That the aha moment is what
makes for a compelling story.
We heard was created to sell Pez
dispensers, which is also not
true.
That if you apply,
retroactively,
a certain clarity of
vision that wasn't there,
it makes it harder when you do
ambitious things in the future.
And so Paul Graham has
two wonderful essays.
Actually, the original title of
the book that I was working on
was "Keep Your Identity Small."
He's saying you have to
keep your identity small
because information
is constantly
changing in the world
and you're constantly
being put in new situations.
And if you have this
overwhelming identity,
or if you have this big
ego, it makes it hard
for you to be flexible,
to try different things,
to see things objectively,
and not through your, again,
overwhelming lens of the world.
And his other essay on-- I
think it's called "Frighteningly
Ambitious Startup Ideas"-- he's
saying that "The way to really
big things seems to actually be
to start with deceptively small
things."
And I think this is
true for most successes.
It's not that it's accidental.
It's that to have thought,
when they were writing that PhD
dissertation or thesis,
that the end outcome of it
would be one of the world's
most valuable companies
and they'd all be billionaires,
that would be preposterous.
This would be preposterously
conceited and dilusional.
And so that wasn't what
they were thinking.
What they were thinking about
is the immediate task at hand.
And so as you go
out into the world
and try to do new
ambitious things,
it requires that you
suppress that ego
so you can see them
clearly and objectively,
and not through
the lens of a story
that you tell
yourself or an image
that you have of yourself.
And so I don't
mean to rub it in,
but you look at Google Glass.
And some of the failures
of Google Glass,
and I think some of
Google's other problems,
have come from the fact that--
being an incredibly successful
company that has built all these
transformational products-- you
start to try to take some
shortcuts and you say, well,
can't we just start with
a transformational idea?
Or you say, this is certainly
going to be transformational,
so let's put tons of
resources behind it.
So what you get away
from is what Paul Graham
is saying-- is you get away from
the deceptively small things.
And this is Bill Walsh was
worried about-- it's getting
away from the deceptively
small things that
actually matter a great deal.
It's having pride or
sportsmanship-- pride
in doing good work-- having
the right work ethic,
holding yourself to a certain
standard of excellence.
These are the things
that win games.
or that put you in a
position to win games.
And you want to make sure
that the fact that you
have won a game
doesn't lead to you
abandoning those principles.
And this happens
time and time again.
And so what I'm
talking about, then,
is learning the right
lessons from your past.
And there's a wonderful quote
from Elizabeth Newell-Newman.
She's an artist and she talks
about one of my favorite books
on creativity.
Actually, the book is
just called "Creativity"
and it's by Mihaly--
I'm not even
going to begin to
butcher his last name.
But if you just look it
up on Amazon or Google it,
it's wonderful.
But she's saying,
"I never look back
except to look at mistakes.
There's only danger in
looking back at things
that you're proud of."
So what I'm talking about,
then-- what I think suppresses
the ego-- is looking
at events retroactively
to find out not what
you did amazingly well
or what's says something
about you as a person,
but instead, where you need
to and where you can improve.
And so, hopefully you'll humor
me for another football story.
This is Tom Brady on draft day.
Tom Brady was drafted 199th in
the NFL draft in the year 2000.
He was drafted in
the sixth round.
And so, in terms of
pure performance, or ROI
this is undoubtedly
the greatest draft pick
in the history of football.
He starts for 14 seasons.
He'll be starting
for his 14th season.
He's been to six Super Bowls.
He's won four times.
Three Super Bowl MVPs.
He's been to the
Pro-Bowl 12 times.
He's thrown for,
like, 60,000 yards.
It's an absurd track record
for a singular quarterback.
He's played all his
years on the same team
and built, probably, the
most dominant franchise
in the history of
football, as well.
But he was drafted
in the sixth round.
Sixth round-- so
it becomes this--
we're going to do all
these other things first,
and maybe, and then
it leads to this.
And so you would think
that the Patriots would
see this as a massive success.
That they got this steal.
But that's actually
not the lesson
that they took from this.
What they took
from it, instead, I
think is a very humble
lesson, and one I
try to apply in my
own life, as well.
They were upset.
Not because they're
perfectionists,
but because the
lesson that Belichick
and his head of
personnel-- his name
was Scott-- no longer
with the Patriots--
but what they took from this
is we were really wrong.
How could we have let
this superstar wait
until the sixth round?
Somebody else could
have taken him.
So what they're seeing, then,
is not that they got this steal,
but how fortuitous that it
worked out in their favor was
and how easily it could
have not gone that way.
Because not only did
they draft him 199th,
but he was set to be the
third-string quarterback.
He barely beat the
second-string quarterback.
And it was only when the
Patriots' starter, Drew
Bledsoe, injured himself in
the Brady's second season,
that Tom Brady was
able to get his shot.
And then he did
so amazingly well,
they ended up winning
the Super Bowl that year.
And so, what the Patriots saw
is how easily this all could
have gone the other direction.
And so I think this
is the opposite
of being full of yourself.
This is-- as I would say,
it's looking for the failure
inside the success.
This is preventing those
things from going to your head.
One of my favorite lines
in the children's book
"The Little Prince"
is he says, "Vain men
never hear anything but praise."
And that's the problem.
If your vanity or
ego is there, all
you're going to
see in your story
is the things that
have gone well.
And you're not going
to see the things
that could have gone better
or that you lucked out.
Again, for some
football, Vince Lombardi
says, nobody ever
wins a championship
and then looks
backwards and says,
man, if the ref
hadn't blown that call
in the middle of the season,
we never would have been here.
Or that if that ball had bounced
inbounds instead out of bounds,
it would be a totally
different story.
We tend to only
look and make it--
we only look at it in our favor.
And so one of the
things the Patriots did,
as a reminder of this-- Scott
Pioli-- he had on his desk--
he had a picture of Dave's-- I
don't want to butcher his name
either-- Stachelski-- he had
a picture of him on his desk
for his rest of the time at
the Patriots because this is
the player that the Patriots
drafted over Tom Brady.
They drafted him
in the fifth round
and he didn't even make
it through training camp.
He ended up having a career
with a couple other teams,
but the guy that they
thought they were confidently
picking in the
fifth round ended up
being not even
remotely close to good
as the guy they got lucky
to get in the sixth round.
So it's this reminder.
Again, it's not
looking backwards
to see what your proud of.
It's looking
backwards to see what
mistakes you might have
made and the things that you
could do better.
I'll give you an
example of my own life.
I wrote a book two
years ago called
"The Obstacle is the Way."
And I think I did
a pretty good job.
But I was not thinking
that this would happen.
I would not think that this
book about ancient philosophy
would somehow make its way
through professional sports.
Coincidentally, also
to the Patriots.
This was not what
I was thinking.
So that's lesson number one.
I was not-- I was--
I have to remember
very vividly that my
intention was to write
a book for business people.
That's what I was thinking.
Or just for people who
are interested in history
and business.
I wanted to write
a book for them.
And it just happened
that it accidentally
made its way into this circle.
So that was lesson number one.
The bigger lesson for me
is that of all the things,
the book has sold pretty well.
But I have to be-- as
I'm launching this book,
I was trying to think, why
was that book successful?
And why did it sell well?
And looking back at
the sales record,
this is-- have you guys
ever heard of BookBub?
It's this cool newsletter
and they recommend
discounted e-books once a day.
So it's sort of like
Groupon for books,
although you don't
buy them from them,
you buy them from
Amazon or any retailer.
So we did-- about three weeks
after the book came out,
I had suggested to my
publisher that we try
this new thing called BookBub.
It wasn't super huge then.
And we tried it.
So we discounted the e-book
from $12.99, or whatever it was,
to $3.99 and it was
supposed to run for a week.
And it ran for a week and it
had a nice spike in sales.
And then-- still don't totally
know how this happened,
but Amazon kept the discount.
And they kept the
discount for 11 months.
We all know that discounting,
in the short term,
can be really great.
The reason you don't
do it in the long term
is it can reduce the
overall amount of revenue.
But Amazon not
only discounted it,
but they discounted it and
they paid the full royalty
the whole time.
So it was just-- I don't know
how it happened, honestly.
I'm very grateful, obviously.
But what I think happened
is we did this service
and it created a spike
in Amazon's algorithm,
and then Amazon-- just like you
guys-- is very smart with data.
And they saw, hey, if we
keep this artificially low,
it will sell over the long term.
And maybe they forgot about it.
I don't know what happened.
But for 11 months, my book was
basically sold as a loss leader
by the biggest
retailer in the world.
And obviously, this contributed
to sales in a huge way.
If I look at the data,
e-book sold way more
than audio book--
or, sorry, e-book
sold way more than audio-- agh.
E-book sold way
more than physical.
And usually,
they're about 60-40.
It was flipped.
And this was a result
of the discounting.
So basically, the book
was able to be discovered,
or people were able to
take a chance on it,
in a way that worked
out very well.
But again, it was
totally unintentional.
So I have to look
at that lesson.
As I'm launching the next book,
I'm not thinking, oh, well,
the baseline is I'm going
to sell as many copies
as the last one.
You have to say, if this
fortuitous event does not
occur again, how is that
going to work out for me?
You don't want to take
for granted something
that you didn't have
anything to do with.
At the same time, the
right lesson, I think,
you take from that is
experimenting and trying
new things can often
work out really well.
And that there can be upsides
that you can't anticipate
for doing things that, maybe,
other people are afraid to do.
And then, also, when
you get a lucky break,
ride that thing for
as long as you can.
We didn't send Amazon
an email and say, hey,
we don't want this.
They opened the door
and we walked through it
and we stayed on the other
side for as long as possible.
And you learn, OK, with books,
there is a price elasticity
in book sales and that
targeted discounting
can be good for discovery.
Again, it's taking
the right lessons
and making sure-- the difference
between-- an objective event
happens.
You win a Super Bowl or
your book sells well.
Or you acquire a site and
it becomes the destination
for all the video in the world.
Or your Stanford thesis becomes
a billion-dollar company.
An objective event
happens-- I would
say learning the right lesson
from that objective event--
to me, evil is the
swing vote there.
Ego-- if you look through the
world with an egotistical lens,
you're going to be
telling yourself,
of course, that this
says something about you
as a person.
That it says you are a genius
or you're a great marketer.
It says this thing about you.
And not only is that dangerous
because it's not true,
but the other side of that coin
is that when things go poorly,
you tell yourself
the same thing.
You tell yourself,
this says something
about me as a person-- that
I'm a failure because my thing
failed and my
company's a failure
because this project failed.
And so it might be nice
when you're on top,
but it's particularly vicious
when fate turns against you.
And my last book
was about stoicism
and the stoics
are always talking
about having an attitude
that's resilient,
in case that always happens.
So ego is that difference.
My favorite stoic quote
is from Marcus Aurelius.
He's saying, "To accept
it without arrogance
and to let it go
with indifference."
And that's what we're
talking about when
it comes to these stories.
Know what's actually
happening, don't
let it puff you up and make
you more than what you are.
But also, when things go
poorly or there's mistakes
or there's problems, or
hey, you write a book
and some news event
interrupts and people
aren't buying books
that week-- that you
know that it's the
standard of performance
that you adhere to that
make this thing quality
and that it will
prevail in the end.
Or whatever that is.
I wanted to leave you
guys with that today.
One meditation on how ego can
manifest itself in success
and how you have to be
on guard against it.
And on a lighter note,
so you didn't think
I was lecturing like that.
Oh, sorry.
This is one of my
favorite quotes.
Sorry, but it goes
to the same point.
This is from Marina
Abramovic and she's
saying, "If you start believing
in your own greatness,
it is the death of
your creativity."
It's not just the death
of your creativity,
I think it's also the
death of the work that
needs to go into bring a
creative thing into the world,
and then into the market.
So ego is that swing vote.
Believing in your
own greatness is
whether you're going to
learn the right lesson,
you're going to tell
yourself the right story.
And humility and
self-awareness is
going to determine whether you
tell yourself the right story.
And I thought I'd leave you
with this picture of my donkey
eating a copy of the book.
But anyway, that's it for me.
Thank you guys for having me.
We can do questions.
[APPLAUSE]
SPEAKER: We've got mics.
RYAN HOLIDAY: Or you can throw
me out for daring to insult
Google.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
Thanks for coming.
RYAN HOLIDAY: Thanks
for having me.
AUDIENCE: I don't know if
you've heard about this,
but I think all Newglers
know about this.
And it's imposter syndrome.
It's this kind of
well known fact
that people who
start working here
don't feel like
they belong here,
or that they deserve
to be working here.
I'm just curious what your
thoughts are about that
in relation to the things
that you just talked about.
RYAN HOLIDAY: Yeah.
I've gone through a
little bit of that myself,
so I understand.
I guess, objectively, what
you tell yourself is look,
the people who hire at
Google are pretty smart.
They're not really in the
business of hiring people who
don't deserve to work there.
And so they're probably right,
even if you might doubt it.
But one of the things I
talk about in the book--
because I think people
sometimes think that ego
is the opposite of humility.
And I'm not sure
that that's true.
I talk in the book-- Aristotle's
golden mean basically
says that all virtues are
a midpoint between two
vices, or two extremes.
So he's saying,
courage is a midpoint
between brashness on
one side and, say,
cowardice on the other.
And so I think
what you're trying
to develop as a human
being-- competence,
then, is a mid-point between
egotism and delusion,
and on the other
hand, self-loathing
and crippling self-doubt.
And I think you get that
confidence not by saying,
oh, this job is important
and I'm not important.
And so therefore,
I'm an imposter.
I think what you look at is you
look at your accomplishments.
You look at the work that went
into getting you where you are.
And again, this is telling
yourself the right story.
It's, I got hired by Google
because I worked hard
in high school and I
got into this college.
And I did well in this school
when other people were doing x.
And I built these
projects on the side,
or I did all these things.
So it's making sure
that you're taking pride
not in the fact that you work
at an amazing, elite company.
It's that you're taking
pride in the work that you do
and who you are and what
you bring to the table.
Does that make sense?
AUDIENCE: Oh, yeah.
RYAN HOLIDAY: Awesome.
AUDIENCE: For sure.
Thank you.
RYAN HOLIDAY: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Two question.
One, I was just curious how you
ended up thinking and writing
about this stuff.
And the other is do you have
any comments mostly Elon Musk?
RYAN HOLIDAY: I think Elon
Musk is really fascinating.
And the whole second
section of the book
opens with the story
of Howard Hughes, who
I find to be fascinating.
He's probably the--
although he was
a brilliant creative
visionary-- probably,
though, single worst
businessman of the 21st century.
He just happened to
inherit a company that
had a monopoly on oil
drilling and funded all
these ridiculous projects.
But actually, I'd always
known about Howard Hughes.
And I'd read a
little bit about him.
But I thought of
him for this book
because I'd read an interview
with Elon Musk where
he said that he'd been
reading about Howard
Hughes as a cautionary tale.
And I think that's really
interesting because they're
both brilliant--
obviously, they're both
fascinated by aviation and
they're both entrepreneurs.
They both created
multiple companies.
But Howard Hughes died
in self-exile and misery
and addiction and insanity.
And so I liked that
he was studying that.
Although, I saw
the news yesterday
about him announcing
that he was going
to acquire one of
his own companies
and being somewhat
mystified that people
would be skeptical of this,
or suspicious of this.
And I think one of the things
that ego makes very difficult
is empathy.
And even if not just empathy--
like, understanding optics.
And so, often, when
you are egotistical
and you're surrounded by people
who are dependent on you,
it becomes very hard for
you to see the world the way
other people who are not
you would see the world.
But that is an essential
skill when you are managing,
not just multiple companies,
but the high wire act
of public relations and
branding involved in the kinds
of companies that he's doing.
So I think Elon Musk
is really interesting.
I don't know him personally
or know enough about him
to make any judgments
one way or another.
But I was fascinated by
ego-- so my last book
was about external obstacles.
And I wanted to write--
I hope I'm not making up
a story here-- I wanted to
write about internal ob-- like,
what makes those
things impossible?
And I found that
self-awareness was
essential in the kind of
objectivity and perseverance
required.
So I was interested in that.
And also, I put my email
in all my books and stuff,
and so I get a lot of
emails from people.
And I tend to find that the
vast majority of the problems
that people are coming
to me with-- it's
clear that it's a completely
self-inflicted problem.
It's just they're not able
to see their own situation
with any sort of objectivity.
They don't see how they're
making things worse
for themselves.
And so I wanted to write about
self-awareness and humility.
And actually, I also was
interested in the way
that social media creates a
sort of weird performance art
where we're all pretending
we're better than we are.
So it was those sort of
things that led into the book.
AUDIENCE: Hey, Ryan.
Thanks for coming.
Big fan.
RYAN HOLIDAY: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: One of the
things that I really
liked about Malcolm
Gladwell's "Outliers"
is that he talks about the story
of the Beatles and Bill Gates
and how we, as a society,
love to feed those egos
and build those things up.
But he talks about how it really
just takes a lot of hard work
and a lot of luck.
RYAN HOLIDAY: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: So I'm curious to
get your perspectives on what
it is that gives us
a tendency to want
to feed other people's egos.
RYAN HOLIDAY: I think
we like those stories
because then-- we're all
trying to do something.
And so it's like, oh, if they
were just brilliant or creative
or if they got this lucky break,
then that bodes well for us.
Or conversely, we use it as
a rationalization for why
we're not pursuing something.
So it's like, oh, they-- that
didn't happen to me so that's
why I'm not successful at
whatever it is that I'm doing.
So you could tell yourself the
wrong story in both directions.
I think a lot of it,
also, is like-- I
read this book a couple years
ago called "The Accidental
City," which is a
history of New Orleans
and how it became
what it became.
And I remember, like, halfway
through, I just quit reading.
I was like, there's
no narrative here.
And it's the whole point
is that it's accidental
and there was no narrative.
But it just made for really
not super exciting reading.
And so I think the other thing
is that, as human beings,
we're hardwired for narrative.
It's how our brains work.
So we gravitate toward
simplifying things and making
them more fated or
ordained or exciting
than they actually were.
I think it's interesting.
I really like Malcolm
Gladwell's stuff, too.
And I think the 10,000 hours
thing is very well supported.
I worked on a book with Robert
Greene called "Mastery,"
and he says it's actually
more like 20,000 hours.
One of the things-- I
have a line in the book.
It's more of a throwaway line.
But I think one
of the hard parts
we see-- even that, we go, oh,
so it just takes 10,000 hours.
And then, we think it's like,
oh, I just check off an hour.
It's not-- it's much more
complicated than that.
Yes.
It took 10,000 hours
for the Beatles
to be great as the Beatles, but
also because of where they were
and the time, and
the influences--
they were making a
living, probably,
before they got 10,000 hours.
Or maybe that's what
it takes for music,
but to be a computer programmer,
it takes 22,000 hours.
There's not some magical
number that you hit
and it's like-- if you run
26.2 miles, that's a marathon.
That's not how it works
for mastering something.
It's like it takes
a really long time,
and then you get pretty good.
And then it still takes
a really long time.
And maybe you never--
there's no finish line.
Does that answer your question?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
RYAN HOLIDAY: All right.
Hal?
AUDIENCE: Quick question
on the perceived values.
We're all in the
business of creating
a perceived value of ourselves.
All of us here, we go to
[INAUDIBLE] et cetera.
RYAN HOLIDAY: Sure.
AUDIENCE: So we--
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
We reflect on our own,
for our egos, et cetera,
and try to grow.
RYAN HOLIDAY: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: But, including
yourself as an author,
you are portraying, like--
RYAN HOLIDAY: Yes.
AUDIENCE: --a certain.
So how do you see that
balancing out and that conflict?
RYAN HOLIDAY: Well,
one of the things
that I think is so interesting
that really motivated
me to write the book is
like, OK-- a friend of mine
said this.
He was like, 20 years ago, only
cult leaders had followers.
Now everyone has followers.
Because we all have
Twitter accounts.
And so in the way that social
media and the way the world
works now, it's
like, everyone has
to have this personal brand.
So it used to be that only
an author or-- even CEOs were
mostly private people.
You didn't know who
ran General Motors.
He's not on Squawk
Box 50 years ago.
So the way in which
we now all have
to have these
personal brands means
that we're all susceptible
to what was once
the temptations and
seductions of fame
for celebrities or performers.
And I could pull up my
Instagram feed right now
and it's going to present
my life in a much more
glamorous way than
whatever happens in
between those photos.
And so we're all
performing in that way.
Sometimes we're
performing in that way--
I might tell myself it's because
I have fought-- sometimes
you tell yourself that
it's part of the branding
or the personal brand
that you're maintaining.
And other times,
it's just you chasing
internet points or
likes and retweets
and hearts and favorites
and all these things.
So I think one of the things
you learn as a marketer is
that there is a distinction
between the distilled message
or campaign that you're doing
and then the complex reality
that is the product
or the company.
And I think people have to
develop a bit of that sense,
too.
That the person you
are at a job interview
is not who you are Sunday
night at home on the couch.
And making sure that
you are not-- the tail
is not wagging the
dog, so to speak.
That the branding and the
marketing-- the illusions
that you're creating to advance
whatever your career are,
or a message that
you have, are not
changing your
perception of yourself.
Because that's-- it's a short
throw from there to living
in a Trumpian fantasy world
where you're qualified to be
president [INAUDIBLE].
AUDIENCE: I have a question.
RYAN HOLIDAY: Oh, all right.
AUDIENCE: Let me see if
I can phrase this well.
A lot of your examples were
about achieving success
and people who have been
successful and many of them
start from the
sea of aspiration.
And it almost seems like, why
is ego-- the topic of ego--
coupled with success?
It seems like you're framing
the idea of not having an ego
as a service to
achieving success.
And that kind of confuses
me because if you
come from stoicism
or Buddhism, they
say the desire is the
[INAUDIBLE] of suffering
in you.
Things like that.
RYAN HOLIDAY: Sure.
AUDIENCE: So is aspiration
itself caused from the ego?
Who's to say that-- Mother
Teresa did amazing work.
How do you know that's
not driven by ego?
But how do you know that
what Steve Jobs did--
that was driven by ego
or not driven by his ego?
How do you-- where do
you draw that line?
RYAN HOLIDAY: No, I think it's
a very interesting question.
Obviously, I think these
topics are fascinating to me
personally and they're
how I try to live my life.
The reality is also
that we live in a world
where people are trying
to accomplish things.
We have individual goals,
we have families to feed,
we have beliefs that we
hold to be very important,
and we are trying to do things.
And so I decided in
this specific book
to look at the
ways that ego makes
what we are trying to do more
difficult than it already is.
Now, also personally, I
think ego makes relationships
very difficult. And it
makes-- ironically--
let's say that ego was only
a minor problem, in terms
of achieving success.
Ego is also a
[INAUDIBLE] in the sense
that it makes it
impossible for you
to feel like your
success is ever enough.
These things are interrelated.
I'm just focusing on
one specific part.
I came to this on
the stoicism book.
I'm really interested
in philosophy,
but most people don't
wake up and think,
I would like to
study philosophy.
I'm like that, maybe
you're like that.
Most people wake up and
they think, I'm bankrupt
or I'm overweight or I
have a number of problems
and I'm depressed, I'm adrift.
Whatever it is.
I need help with that problem.
And my understanding of
these ancient philosophies
is that they are designed
to help with those things.
Certainly, stoicism is a
much more Western philosophy,
so unlike-- the image
of the stoic philosopher
is not-- in the way
that a Buddhist might
be in a beautiful temple
on top of a rocky mountain
or in a lush garden.
The stoic philosopher is
the man in the marketplace,
the emperor, the general.
Someone who has a job
that they have to do
and they're looking for guidance
on how to do that thing well.
So I think you
raise a great point.
This is not just about how
to aspire and achieve things.
And you want to
make sure that when
you are driven--
when you are trying
to do those things--
that it's not
out of ego in and of itself.
But plenty of divorces
are caused by ego
and plenty of
miserable childhoods
are the result of
egotistical parents,
and so on and so forth.
So I think they're very related.
But that's just what
this book is about.
AUDIENCE: Well, thank you.
I loved your last
book, by the way.
I look forward to
reading this one.
SPEAKER: I think that's
all the time we have.
RYAN HOLIDAY: Cool.
SPEAKER: Let's give Ryan
another round of applause.
RYAN HOLIDAY: Thank you, guys.